[Musique]
et on va passer au débat de ce club on
va longuement parler évidemment des
différents aspects de ce texte mais pour
commencer je voudrais vous vous poser
une question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'immigration est une chance pour la
France je pense que c'est plus une
chance pour les personnes qui ont choisi
de venir en France euh ça peut être une
chance pour la France mais clairement
les Français nous disent à aux environs
de 80 % qu'il n'en peuvent plus cette
immigration incontrôlée où ils n'ont
jamais été consultés vraiment ni
directement où on leur a dit pendant des
années ben vous ne voyez pas ce qui
existe et maintenant on leur dit bah la
situation c'est comme ça on peut rien
faire je pense que c'est une grande
souffrance pour à la fois les personnes
qui sont au main de trafiquant d'êtres
humains et qui arrivent dans des
conditions abominables et puis pour les
Français qui sont forcés de faire en
sorte que Ben de les accueillir et c'est
pour ça qu'on a des oxyorts comme vivre
ensemble et cetera non c'est une grande
douleur je crois pour pour tout le monde
quand on se balade à Paris par exemple
puisque nous sommes à Paris aujourd'hui
et bien on voit que le plus grand
camping d'Europe ben c'est le
périphérique ce sont des conditions
abominables alors pendant des années la
France a été une terre d'asile une terre
d'accueil aujourd'hui toutes nos
procédures sont détournées et puis je
pense qu'il faut aussi prendre un petit
peu de hauteur et regarder ce qui se
passe dans tous les pays européens tous
les pays européens disent stop et ce
sont pas des régimes fascistes hein vous
avez l'Allemagne avec un un démocrate un
socialdémocrate la Hollande la Suède et
cetera où la situation de l'immigration
est hors de contrôle depuis une bonne
dizaine d'années maintenant et je pense
que ça c'est une souffrance pour tout le
monde hein mais je pense qu'en réalité
ça dépend beaucoup de la capacité qu'on
se donne à intégrer à faire de ce qui
arrivent sur notre territoire des
Français comment est-ce qu'on permet
l'apprentissage de la langue
l'intégration par le travail par l'école
quand on a quand on a des enfants et je
pense que c'est ça le défi auquel on est
confronté et c'est précisément parce que
les États ne prennent pas en charge
parce qu'ils ne sont pas au rendez-vous
qu'on ouvre un marché considérable pour
des traficant et pour des gens qui
prospèrent sur la misère humaine c'est
parce que vous n'avez pas d'hébergement
digne que vous avez des marchands de
sommeil qui en profitent c'est parce que
vous n'avez pas par exemple de
régularisation par le travail que vous
avez des patrons qui en profitent pour
prospérer là aussi sur une forme
d'exploitation et et de misère humaine
et donc la vraie question c'est comment
on s'organise pour accueillir tous ceux
qui ont fait croire à l'immigration zéro
en réalité se sont cassés les dents
regardez en Italie regardez Georgia
Meloni elle a passé toute sa campagne
électorale à expliquer avec moi il n'y
aura plus d'immigration et aujourd'hui
elle en est à mendier le soutien de
l'Union européenne pour organiser
l'accueil de ceux qui viennent de ceux
qui viennent chez elle donc on voit bien
qu'en réalité c'est un mirage
d'expliquer qu'il n'y aura pas
d'immigration il y en aura la question
est comment on s'organise et si on ne
s'organise pas effectivement de fait on
provoque le le chaos moi je préfère
l'organisation au chaos h bon personne
ne souhaite le chaos le chaos c'est
aujourd'hui dire que les États N sont
pas au rendez-vous c'est entièrement
faux la France et l'Europe ça fait
partie de la région du monde où le monde
entier souhait venir y compris en
critiquant la France y compris en
sautant de joie dans les camps de
réfugiés quand il y a eu les programmes
abominables en Israël c'est quand même
une réalité mais surtout ça coûte très
cher aux Français et euh les études nous
prouvent parce que c'est vrai que l'État
organise aussi le fait que d'avoir des
difficultés à donner des chiffres bon
euh il y en a plusieurs dont celle de
Jean-Paul gourevic qui est la plus connu
euh qui dit que pour l'année 2023
l'immigration ça coûté 57 55 ou 57
milliards d'euros les années précédentes
c'était 40 milliards d'euros donc on
voit que ce sont des sommes
considérables et dire que on n'accueille
pas mais c'est mais c'est mentir aux
Français d'ailleurs il le voit dans le
logement à l'école à l'hôpital on
accueille et aussi l'immigration euh est
surreésenté à la fois dans le chômage
parce qu'on a
560000 étrangers au chômage aujourd'hui
sans compter les sans papierers ça c'est
un autre sujet enfin pas les sans papier
les personnes qui s'organisent pour ne
pas avoir de papi ils en nont mais ils
veulent pas les donner c'est un autre
sujet et vous avez
également l'immigration qui est
surreprésenté dans tout ce qui est crime
délit délinquence et cetera donc ça
c'est c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure
j'enis le terme de souffrance la réponse
y an bra après on va parler de l'article
3 moi je partage pas l'idée selon
laquelle la grande masse des étrangers
qui vivent sur notre territoire
viendrait déstabiliser notre pays il
suffit de se promener dans dans les rues
aux alentours pour voir que la grande
masse des étrangers travaillent qu'ils
aient des papiers ou pas d'ailleurs
aller dans un aller dans un restaurant
vous tomberez sur allez dans un je vous
ai pas coupé madame voyz allez dans un
restaurant vous tomberez dans les
cuisines sur des cuisiniers qui n'ont
pas de papier et qui pourtant
travaillent allez alleer dans les
bureaux de la défense et vous verrez
qu'à 6h 7h du matin les femmes qui font
le ménage n'ont pas de papier ce sont
celles qui prennent le premier métro et
donc cette réalité là à un moment donné
il va bien falloir la regarder en face
et donc soit vous faites semblant
termine soit vous faites semblant que ça
n'existe pas soit vous leur permettez
d'avoir accès à des droits comme
n'importe quel travaur suis contre
lubérisation de la société dans tous les
domaines et notamment dans le travail
des sans papiers des des clandestins
parce que ce sont des clandestins je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut pas
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
non plus effectivement aujourd'hui on
emploi enfin c'est pas la majorité je
rappelle que les étrangers en situation
régulière sont surreprésentés dans le
chômage c'est à peu près le double que
les Français sans origine immigré ça
sont les chiffres de l'INC mais surtout
que nous avons 560000 étrangers en
situation régulière au chômage
aujourd'hui et que la France accueille
une immigration enfin prend en charge
une immigration qui est très qui n'est
pas qualifié c'est un des problèmes
quant aux personnes qui travaillent dans
en étant clandestine je p je pense que
c'est une un problème d'organisation du
travail parce qu'avec un sommage aussi
élevé qu'en France avec des minimas
sociaux aussi important qu'en France je
pense notamment au RSA où les étrangers
sont aussi
surreprésentés comment voulez-vous com
voulez-vous qu'on régularise et qu'on
fasse un nouvel appel d' aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est un problème
d'organisation du travail et même et
même le le le MDEF qu'on a souvent pris
à parti pour dire c'est les employeurs
qui veulent non dit que aujourd'hui il
faut faire qu'est-ce qu'on fait du
million de jeunes qui sont sans emploi
qui font pas aller
dans pas faire venir de la misère qui se
rajoute aux difficultés énormes que nous
avons je vous ai pas parlé de gens à
faire venir je vous ai parlé de gens qui
sont déjà là je vous ai parler du fait
que non non je vous ai parlé du fait que
dépend entiers de notre économie
aujourd'hui repose sur des personnes qui
sont sans papier mais je voudrais
revenir sur la question des aide et des
allocations parce que depuis tout à
l'heure tout votre argumentaire vise à
expliquer que ces gens viennent en
France pour bénéficier d quelle est la
réalité on prendrai quelques exemples
sur le RSA 70 % des étrangers en
situation régulière et qui ne sont pas
issu de l'union européenne qui aurait
droit au RSA qui aurait droit au RSA n'y
ont pas recours vous avez un taux de non
recours de 70 % quant à la me mais je
crois qu'on doit en parler tout à
l'heure sur l'aide médicale d'État 50 %
des étrangers qui auraient droit à
l'aide médicale d'État n'y ont pas
recours donc je veux bien qu'on nous
explique que tous ces gens que tous ces
gens viennent en France pour bénéficier
d'aide la réalité c'est que si c'était
le cas ils y auraient quand ils y ont
droit donc il est un peu facile d'aller
expliquer en
perman
bénéf
coû on va continuer à parler des
travailleurs dans les les métiers en
tenstion et on va voir ce qui se passe
dans les restaurants BR puisque vous en
parliz qu' pense les employeurs et les
salariés en situation irrégulière Sam
Adrien sont allés le poser la question
on regarde leur
témoignage l'entrée du jour je peux
l'avoir voilà 20 ans qu'alin Fontaine a
racheté ce restaurant parisien pour
faire tourner son équipe de 26 salariés
il a besoin de la main d'œuvre étrangère
et ne s'en cache pas certains sont
parfois en situation irrégulière j'ai eu
des collaborateur en situation
irrégulière nous les avons régularisé
parce que j'avais personne pour les
remplacer contrairement à ce que disent
certaines personnes de dire que oui mais
il faut faire travailler les uns et les
autres non on avait personne pour les
remplacer je c'est ce que les salaires
proposés sont les mêmes salaires pour
tout le monde à travail égal salaire
égal là aussi quand des détracteurs
disent oui mais c'est pour les spayés
c'est faux et entièrement faux et donc
oui il a fallu régulariser oui c'est
long ça peut prendre entre 1 an et 4 ans
la plupart du temps ces salariés ont
d'abord été embauchés comme apprentis
lorsqu'ils étaient mineurs à leur
majorité ils se retrouvent en situation
irrégulière pourquoi ça nous emmè de
laisser partir parce que vous moi on a
payé leur formation
moi en tant que patron que je sois
plombier électricien chocolatier ou
cuisinier j'ai passé 4 ans à former des
des filles et des garçons et là on perd
tout on perd on perd l'investissement
c'est pas normal tous les entrepreneurs
ne sont pas pour autant favorables à la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier dans les métiers en tension dans
d'autres secteurs certains profitent de
cette main d'œuvre
vulnérable voilà 5 ans qu'Ibrahima et
Mamadou vivent en France ils sont
intérimaires dans l'industrie cotisent
payent des impôts mais n'ont quasiment
aucun droit en 2020 au moment de covid
moi je me suis blessé j'ai fait un
accident de travail au boulot mais je
peux pas
arrêter ma main était gravement coupée
mais je pourrais pas arrêter en ce
moment et parce que je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas une sécurité sociale là o des
sommages que je peux prendre à la maison
je n'en ai pas et si je reste à la
maison aussi qui va essayer de me
prendre en charge depuis le 17 octobre
ils sont en greffe pour obtenir leur
régularisation ils ont besoin d'une
promesse d'embauche de leur employeur un
document indispensable pour déposer une
demande en préfecture mais il n'est pas
facile à obtenir a des patrons qui sont
qui ne donne pas qui reféuse parce que
voilà il veut pas sinon s'il te donne
voilà demain ou lemain tu as situation
régulière tu tu peux réclamer tout tes
droits devant lui comme eux 650
travailleurs 100 papiers sont en grève
soutenu par la CGT 630 ont obtenu une
promesse d'embauche de leur employeurs
mais l'étape suivante est tout aussi
difficile celle du rendez-vous en
préfecture où la décision est laissée à
la libre appréciation des préfets que
nous voulons c'est d'avoir des critères
communs pour l'ensemble des préfectures
c'est-àdire que les travailleurs soient
traités de la même manière qu'il soit à
Paris en sc s dans le valdear dans les
hautes scènes avec cette grève ils
espèrent aussi influencer le débat en
cours au Sénat sur la loi immigration
avec l'ensemble des grvistes on va aller
jusque devant le Sénat en manifestation
pour dire quelle est la réalité des
travailleurs sans papier ce pays et que
de dire que si vous êtes pas là et bien
en fait la France s'arrête de tourner il
y a plus de chantier il y a plus de
restaurant voilà maintenant 3 semaines
qu'ils sont en grève mais se disent
déterminés à tenir jusqu'au bout pour
obtenir leur
régularisation Valérie Boyet vous avez
entendu le témoignage de ce restaurateur
qui qui emploie des personnes en
situation régulière et il dit mais moi
j'ai personne pour les remplacer bah
vous savez combien il y a de jeunes
aujourd'hui il y en a 1 million en
France qui sont ni à l'école qui ont
rien qu'est-ce qu'on fait vous pensez
que c'est en faisant venir des personnes
clandestines et en donnant une prime à
la fraude qu'on va s'en
sortir sachant madame que quand même
aujourd'hui sous Emmanuel Macron 2 on a
fait rentrer 2 millions d'étrangers en
France je répète les
étrangers en France en situation
régulière sont plus au chômage que les
Français c'est ces métiers qui sont
sousqualifiés mais je pense que c'est un
problème d'organisation du travail et
d'être social on peut pas d'un côté
avoir autant de chômeurs avoir autant de
personnes qui vivent des minimas sociaux
des Français des jeunes Français ou des
ou des étrangers en situation régulière
qui vivent en France qui sont au chômage
et créer un appel d' avec des personnes
qui sont rentrées par rraction ça vrait
ça voudrait dire qu'on c'est une prime à
la fraude un appel d'air alors que
partout ça craque quand on disait tout à
l'heure que ça ne déstabilisait pas la
société c'est faux là on parle dans le
reportage on évoque des mineurs
c'est-à-d des mineurs des soi-disant
mineurs et soi-disant isolés parce
qu'ils sont souvent pas mineurs et pas
isolés puisqu'on sait très bien qu'ils
sont dans les mains de réseau ça coûte
vous savez combien par mineur non par
par MNA comme on dit aujourd'hui au
département ça coûte 50000 € pour pour
leur hébergement aujourd'hui les
départements dit au secours nous ne
pouvons plus prendre en en charge
l'enfance en danger c'est-à-dire les
gamins qui aujourd'hui doivent être mis
à l'abri dans dans dans ce qu'on appelle
l'Aide Sociale à en France la ze les
départements ne peuvent plus le faire
parce qu'ils sont submergés
financièrement socialement j'allais dire
par le politiquement
aussi mais c'est plus il y a pas que
celui-ci mais c'est un angl mort majeur
parce que soit-disant ce texte Gérald
armanin sur sur l'IM c'est l'alpha et
l'oméga de du truc c'est faux on n' pas
les MNA les MNA c'est plus de 2
milliards d'euros et après il faut quand
même que les Français sachent nous avons
des circulaires des circulaires pour
qu'ils deviennent français donc c'est un
appel d'air et ensuite il y a le
regroupement familial on ne s'en sort
plus d'abord on peut pas tout mélanger
on parle en l'occurrence de de
travailleurs donc on parle absolument
pas là de de de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance on parle de gens on parle de
gens qui produisent des richesses qui
contribuent aux richesses de notre pays
et qui participent au rayonnement de la
France dans des seeurs qui de plus sont
stratégiques la
restauration l'hôtellerie les bâtiments
les les les bâtiments publics notamment
les infrastructure publique mais on ne
peut pas durablement avoir dans notre
pays deux catégories de travailleurs
d'un côté des travailleurs qui ont des
papiers et qui ont des droits et de
l'autre des travailleurs qui n'ont pas
de papier et qui n'ont pas de droit
pourquoi parce que c'est à la fois si je
peux juste en terminer je vous ai jamais
interrompu c'est à la fois mauvais pour
eux parce que cela ne leur permet pas
d'avoir accès à leurs droits
fondamentaux c'est mauvais pour
l'ensemble du monde du travail parce que
c'est ce qui crée du dumping social et
c'est ce qui fait que on exerce une
pression sur les salaires des Français
et par ailleurs je voudrais quand même
insister sur un point parce que je
voudrais que vous mexpliquer je voudrais
que vous m'expliquiez la position de
votre groupe votre groupe en commission
des lois au Sénat a supprimé purement et
simplement l'article 8 qui permet de
pénaliser les employeurs qui siamment
font le choix d'embaucher des
travailleurs sans papier j'aimerais que
vous m'expliquiez comment vous pouvez
dire d'un côté que vous voulez lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine et dans
le même temps exonérer les employeur de
toute forme de responsabilité ce que
vous organisez c'est l'impunité
patronale et excusez-moi de vous le dire
mais quand il y a une relation
d'exploitation et il y a parfois une
relation d'exploitation dans ces cas-là
la responsabilité c'est pas celle de
l'exploité c'est celle de l'exploiteur
et donc c'est celle du patron qui fait
le choix siamant d'utiliser la misère
humaine d'exploiter la misère humaine
pour payer le moins cher possible et
accorder le moins de droits possible
donc expliquez-moi pourquoi vous avez
supprimé l'article 8 qui permet de
pénaliser les employeurs qui font le
choix d'embaucher des sans papier
d'abord je pense que vous détournez ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
effectivement des employeurs peuvent
demander de façon exceptionnelle et
c'est le pouvoir discrétionnaire du
Préfet de régulariser des personnes qui
sont clandestines parce que le terme
sans papier est un abus de langage ces
personnes ont des papiers ne veulent pas
les donnés ets sont venus dans la
clandestinité en France ou se
maintiennent en France dans la
clandestinité ce sont des déboutés du
droit d'asile ce sont des personnes
qui étudiants et demain ce que l'on
demande demain ce que le texte de Darman
propose c'est que ce soit ces personnesl
qui demandent à être régularisé de toute
façon nous sommes totalement nous sommes
totalement opposés à la
régularisation des personnes
clandestines parce que nous ne voulons
pas de prime à la fraude et régulariser
ces personnes c'est ne pas c'est ne pas
se poser si je pense qu'il faut
maintenir ses sanctions c'est ne pas se
poser la question de savoir ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui des chômeurs des
chômeurs étrangers et de la
surreprésentation de ces personnes dans
les minimas sociaux et puis de tout ce
millions de jeunes Français qui n'ont
rien à un moment donné c'est la vraie
question qu'il faut se poser on va
avancer sur ce texte parce que il y a
évidemment d'autres mesures Alex on va
voir avec vous les mesures du volet
fermeté sécurité de ce projet de loi
effectivement Rian ce projet de loi il
facilite les expulsions de tous les
étrangers même ce en situation régulière
tous les étrangers qui ont été condamnés
pour des crimes ou des délits passibles
de moins 10 ans de prison et il prévoit
également l'expul ulion des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui représente une
menace grave pour l'ordre public et même
s'ils ont des liens personnels et
familiaux avec la France et durant dans
durant le débat au Sénat dans
l'hémicycle et bien le gouvernement le
ministre de l'Intérieur geréralarmanin
va déposer un autre amendement pour
faciliter l'expulsion des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui ne
respecteraiit pas les valeurs de la
République par exemple la liberté
d'expression ou l'égalité hommes-femm y
BR est-ce qu'il n'y a pas nécessité
d'être plus ferme c'est ce que demandent
les Français qui sont en grande majorité
d'accord avec ce texte mais qu'on soit
ferme extrêmement ferme contre les
délinquants contre les criminels ne me
pose aucun problème et donc en
l'occurrence quand on est coupable d'un
délit ou quand on est coupable d'un
crime on a vocation à être puni il y a
pas de débat là-dessus ce que je ce que
je me refuse à considérer c'est qu'on
puisse résumer la question de
l'immigration des étrangers qui vivent
sur notre territoire aux enjeux de
l'insécurité et de la délinquence parce
que je trouve que c'est une une
assimilation qui est extrêmement
insultante pour la grande masse des
étrangers qui vivent sur notre sol et
qui demandent simplement à vivre
dignement avec leur famille pour le
reste qu'on met en prison qu'on condamne
à des peines des gens qui se comportent
mal sur le territoire français
évidemment que ça ne me pose aucune
espèce de problème mais de même que un
criminel ou un délinquant français il
faut qu'il soit
puni et qu'il soit puni sévèrement non
moi je ne suis pas favorable à la double
peine d'ailleurs c'est Nicolas Sarkozi
qui avait mis fin à la double peine mais
pour le reste qu' punisse qui se
comporte mal ça ne me pose en soi aucune
espèce de problème c'est ce qui permet
d'ailleurs de protéger la société de
gens qui n'ont pas vocation à être dans
la nature bah je peux pas dire on peut
enfin c'est vraiment une vue de l'esprit
de dire qu'on résume le texte
immigration à l'insécurité maintenant
c'est une réalité de dire qu'on a menti
aux Français pendant des années en leur
disant que ce qu'ils observaient
n'existait pas aujourd'hui le réel nous
explose à la figure euh et effectivement
euh dire qu'on on n'accueille pas que ça
coûte pas cher et cetera c'est une folie
tous les pays européens sont dans la
même impasse migratoire donc aujourd'hui
il faut dire stop et la réalité de la
surreprésentation des étrangers je le
dis dans l'insécurité dans le chômage
dans dans tous les dispositifs sociaux
c'est une réalité chiffrée voilà
l'immigration ça coûte très cher à la
France et il n'y a pas de de promesse
euh d'Eldorado en France bien au
contraire je rappelle que nous sommes un
des pays les plus endettés de l'Union
européenne que cette dette pèse et
qu'aujourd'hui le poids de l'immigration
en France est considérable je veux dire
50 plus de 50 milliards d'euros par an
vous avez voté hier soir des quotas
migratoires annuels est-ce que c'est une
mesure réellement efficace bah en tout
cas ça permet au Parlement de s'emparer
de la question c'est déjà bien parce que
jusqu'à présent c'était pas le cas c'est
une mesure qu'on réclamait depuis
longtemps je pense que c'est essentiel
compte tenu du poids que ça dans notre
notre société aujourd'hui que c'est la
mer des batailles que c'est central on a
beau se cacher derrière le petit doigt
c'est une réalité 80 % des Français
disent veulent dire STOP donc la moindre
des choses c'est que la représentation
nationale discute de ses quotas et qu'on
choisissent notre immigration
l'immigration c'est un choix du pays
d'accueil c'est pas le choix des
personnes qui ont décidé pour des
raisons qui leur appartiennent de
franchir le nos frontières pour pouvoir
quand même on est le seul endroit du
monde ou quand on franchit les
frontières de l'Union européenne on peut
pas en repartir c'est où vous avez vu ça
ailleurs dans le monde et non seulement
vous venez mais vous bénéficier de
toutes les aides sociales et quand on
veut prendre des mesures pour dire c'est
pas possible c'est à nous de choisir on
passe pour pour des méchants non la
France est très généreuse je rappelle
que soit Emmanuel Macron 2 plus de 2
millions de personnes sont venu en
France à un moment donné c'est normal
que les Français aient le droit de
choisir et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons une modification de la
Constitution un référendum Yan Brossard
non mais peut-être un mot sur les quotas
est-ce que c'est bien que le Parlement s
par de ce sujet que le Parlement puisse
débattre des question d'immigration
c'est normal et qu'un pays puisse
décider qui rentre sur son territoire ça
n'est absolument pas choquant ça fait
partie de la souveraineté du pays la
question est quelle orientation on donne
à notre politique à notre politique
migratoire et en l'occurrence les quotas
ça ne me paraît pas répondre
fondamentalement au sujets auquel on est
confronté d'abord parce que tout ce qui
concerne le droit d'asile ne rentre pas
dans le cadre de la discussion sur les
quotas donc ça concerne le reste de
l'immigration ça concerne notamment
l'immigration étudiante est-ce qu'on
souhaite qu'il y ait moins d'étudiants
étrangers en France je vous le dis très
sincèrement je ne suis pas favorable à
ce qu'on accueille moins d'étudiants et
je pense que le fait d'avoir des
étudiants étrangers est une bonne chose
et pour eux et pour nous avoir des
chercheurs étrangers c'est bien et pour
eux et pour nous quant à l'idée parce
que ça a été débattu hier au Sénat de
limiter le regroupement familial je ne
suis pas favorable à ce qu'on limite le
regroupement familial d'abord parce que
le droit de vivre en famille est un
droit fondamental et par ailleurs si on
souhaite que les gens s'intègrent on a
intérêt à ce qu'ils a leur famille avec
eux et pas au pays parce qu'il va
falloir qu'on m'explique comment on peut
s'intégrer dans une société quand on a
sa famille qui reste au pays et vous
savez moi moi je je je suis élu de Paris
élu du 18e arrondissement je vois
beaucoup d'hommes qui sont des des
chibanis des des vieux migrants qu'on a
fait venir dans les années 70 notamment
pour travailler dans l'automobile ils
ont vécu toute leur vie dans un hôtel
avec leur famille qui restai au pays
est-ce que c'est ça notre modèle
d'intégration ça n'est pas le mien en
tout cas et je pense que si on a envie
que les gens s'intègrent dans la société
française on a besoin qu'ils puissent
vivre avec leur famille ici on va en
parler je précise juste que le Sénat a
donc voté hier un durcissement des
conditions du regroupement familial en
exigeant des demandeurs une assurance
maladie pour eux et pour les membres de
leur famille qui souhait venir en France
est-ce que c'est un frein à
l'intégration de limiter le regroupement
familial comme le dit Anne brossa bah
écoutez on peut pas dire que la France
n'accueille pas je répète encore 2
millions de personnes qui sont arrivées
en France enfin on est on ne sait pas
combien on a de clandestin non plus au
aujourd'hui donc à un moment donné bien
sûr qu'il faut limiter le regroupement
familial je rappelle que nous sommes bon
déjà nous étions dans une situation qui
était difficile euh Macron un KO
migratoire avec la guerre en Syrie nous
avons accueilli beaucoup de dubliné
d'Allemagne
euh premièrement et puis surtout la loi
colon a élargi les conditions du
regroupement familial alors que nous
nous souhaitions nous avions voté contre
hein à l'Assemblée nationale euh donc
moi je suis pour euh j'aurais voulu
qu'on a plus loin mais aujourd'hui on
est passé vous voyez le gros
durcissement de la loi d'armana on est
passé de on a 24 mois de de résidence en
France c'est quand même pas grand-chose
et puis la moindre des choses quand on
vient en France c'est pour travailler
c'est parce que la France souhaite a
besoini on en a pas besoin cont tenu des
éléments que je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure mais la moindre des choses c'est
d'être indépendant et et de de pouvoir
s'assumer ou vous avez vu un pays où
vous arrivez et vous ne pouvez pas vous
ne pouvez pas sur vivre dans ce pays par
votre travail c'est pas possible on on
ne vient pas en France pour pointer au
chômage ou à l'aide sociale c'est pas
possible donc à un moment donné c'est
normal de durcir les conditions enfin
c'est pas un gros durcissement parce que
ça fait partie aussi des du gruillère de
ce texte de la loi d'armanin on va
parler d'un a plus de trou que de que de
Réal un autre point de ce test c'est
l'aide médicale d'État ça fait débat
entre la majorité sénatoriale et le
gouvernement Alex mais oui cette aide
médicale d'État elle couvre les soins de
certains étrangers notamment ceux qui
ont un titre de séjour de moins de 3
mois laame représente un budget annuel
d'1,2 milliard d'euros et couvre les
soins de 400000 bénéficière la majorité
de droite et du centre du Sénat veut
transformer cette aide médicale d'État
en une aide médicale d'urgence avec un
panier de soins qui serait restreint
c'est une réforme qui est partagée à
titre personnel par Gérald daranin le
ministre de l'intérieur mais une réforme
qui est refusée par la première-
ministre ellisabeth borne la première
ministre qui s'appuie sur un rapport
qu'elle a commandé sur le sujet et ce
rapport il stipule que l'aide médicale
d'État est utile peu coûteuse au regard
des 400000 bénéficiaires et ne crée pas
d'appel d'air migratoire un rapport
signé par un certain Patrick stéphanini
ancien directeur de campagne de François
Fillon ouais il éidment il y a
effectivement des divisions au
Gouvernement sur ce sujet Gérald
harmanin qui est sur la position des
sénateurs Yann brossa vous lui demandez
de changer d'avis vous
je lui demande de lire le rapport qui a
été commandé par la première ministre en
l'occurrence c'est un rapport pluraliste
puisqu'il est rédigé à la fois par un
ancien ministre socialiste ministre de
la Santé Claudé vin et une personnalité
dont on peut dire qu'elle n'est pas
vraiment de gauche hein Patrick
stéphanini qui était je crois l'ancien
directeur de campagne de de Valérie
pcres que que vous souteniez je crois
Valérie Boyer et et en l'occurrence et
en l'occurrence quand on établit les
faits de quoi on s'aperç de quoi on
s'aperçoit d'abord les dépenses de laame
de l'aide médicale d'État c'est 0,5 %
des dépenses de l'assurance maladie donc
aller expliquer que ce sont des dépenses
absolument monstrueuse et que si
aujourd'hui l'assurance maladie est en
difficulté c'est à cause de l'aide
médicale d'État c'est faux mais surtout
et je vous voudrais insister là-dessus
c'est une question de santé publique on
a aucun intérêt aucun intérêt à laisser
des gens développer leur maladie parce
que une fois que nous les prendrons en
charge ça nous coûtera plus cher et donc
au final y compris en terme économique
en terme financiers ça n'est pas notre
intérêt de ne pas traiter les gens dès
le départ et puis je note qu'un certain
nombre de pays qui avaient supprimé
l'aide médicale d'État je pense en
particulier à l'Espagne sont revenus sur
leur décision précisément parce qu'ils
se sont aperçus que c'était totalement
contre-productif donc je pense que le
gouvernement gagnerait à en rester aux
dispositions actuelles c'est quand même
un coup dur pour vous ce rapport de
Patrick stéphanini Valérie Boyet qui dit
que l'êre médicale est utile et qu' faut
pas réform il est bien évident qu'il est
utile de soigner les personnes qui sont
sur notre sol et qui sont malades on est
on n jamais dit l'inverse mais l'aide
médicale d'urgence en fait on est en
train de nous expliquer qu'on peut rien
faire c'est exactement le débat que nous
avons ce matin on peut rien faire pour
les les clandestins parce que c'est eux
qui font soutenir l'économie alors que
c'est faux on le démontre avec quand
même des chiffres on peut rien faire
pour l'aide médicale d'État en fait on
peut continuer à rien faire continuer à
faire en sorte que les Français soient
encore dans la souffrance et l'inaction
non je pense que c'est très important de
faire en sorte que cette aide soit
transformée en aide médicale d'urgence
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne va pas
soigner les gens mais ça veut dire qu'on
va faire des choses différemment ça
c'est voilà et je pense que c'est un
point qui est extrêmement important il
faut quand même que les Français
comprennent bien que cette ame qui est
réservé aux personnes clandestines
c'est-à-dire qui ont choisi de venir par
effraction en France et qui ne donnent
pas leur papi après elle se transfore au
bout de 3 mois en régime normal donc et
que ça nous permet aussi d'évaluer le
nombre de clandestins en France puisque
tout à l'heure monsieur brossal disait
également que aujourd'hui on sait très
bien que un sur de demande de bénéficier
de cette médicale d'État euh de cette
ame donc et qu'on sait qu'il y en a à
peu près le dou ça c'est un facteur pour
évaluer le nombre de clandestins en
France donc est-ce qu'on veut faire en
sorte que la situation soit encore ne
soit pas contrôlé en France est-ce que
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est bien de
continuer comme ça nous on pense pas et
c'est pour ça qu'on trouve que le texte
de Gérald daranin est insuffisant c'est
pour ça qu'on souhaite mettre des
mesures qui soient concrètes et qui
soient à la fois du domaine de la
réalité mais aussi du symbole je pense
qu'on ne peut pas dire on peut pas avoir
un panneau en disant
France continuons à faire comme on a
fait vous pouvez rentrer vous pourrez
jamais partir et vous bénéficiez de
toutes les aides sociales aujourd'hui
quel que soit votre statut c'est non ce
n'est plus possible les Français disent
stopan BR dernier d'abord je le redis
les gens qui viennent sur notre
territoire ne viennent pas d'abord
profiter d'aide et on ne vient pas en
France parce qu'on est attiré par les
aides que la France met en place mais
parce qu'on fuit mais parce qu'on fuit
le pays dont on part c'est ça la réalité
et donc
il mais il y a plein de raisons qui qui
font confu un pays il peut y avoir des
raisons politiques il peut y avoir des
raisons économiques il peut y avoir des
raisons climatiques et donc expliquer
l'immigration par la situation dans le
pays d'accueil à savoir que la France
serait trop attractive c'est oublier
qu'on part d'abord en raison des
conditions dans les pays de départ et
d'ailleurs je suis frappé par ça c'est
que ce tra ne traite ce texte pardon ne
traite absolument pas de la manière dont
on change les rapports nord- sudud pour
faire en sorte que les causes des
migration soit Aries or c'est quand même
l'un des principaux sujets auquels on
est confronté et et et qui est un sujet
qui va s'accroître dans les années qui
viennent on on est d'accord ce texte est
très largement insuffisant très
largement en dessous des demandes des
Français c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons durcir ce texte enfin
nous souhaitons c'est pas durcir nous
souhaitons répondre aux attentes des
Français en proposant des mesures pour
que cette souffrance migratoire puisse
être atténué et nous souhaitons bien
évidemment une modification de la
Constitution pour que les Français
reprennent en main leur destin et se
prononce directement là-dessus cette
proposition fait consensus les Français
ont envie de s'exprimer sur cette
question et on suivra l'exam de ce texte
toute cette semaine au Sénat si vous
voulez bien rester avec nous on regarde
ce qu'elle une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux Alex on commence par cette
question à la unee du Dauphiné Libéré
va-t-on vivre une nouvelle pénurie de
médicament cet hiver et oui l'alerte est
donnée par les pharmaciens cet automne
certains médicaments sont déjà en
rupture de stock il y a des tensions
d'approvisionnement pour les
antibiotiques des inquiétudes qui
concernent les molécules qui fabriquent
les anesthésiants les tranquillisants
alors en face le ministre de la Santé
Aurélien Rousseau estime que les stocks
de médicaments de secours sont plein et
il va quand même réunir les acteurs de
la chaîne du médicament cette semaine
pour voir où se situent les différents
points de blocage les intempéries qui se
poursuivent en France et provoque des
inondations et oui après les tempêtes
après le déluge les inondations c'est à
la Une du journal Le Populaire du centre
car dans le Limousin les cours d'eau
sont sortis de leur lit sous l'effet des
fortes pluies de ces derniers jours
c'est le cas aussi dans les haut de
France la région sous les eaux titre le
journal La voie du Nord et les habitants
de certains villages inondés n'en croi
pas leurs yeux dans le village de bourt
dans le Pas de Calais il y a jusqu'à 1
M60 d'eau dans les maisons certains
habitants voient leur rez-de-chaussée
complètement sinistré et les
professionnels font preuve d'innovation
pour aller travailler par exemple
Marie-André aide à domicile dans la
commune de zitepine dans le Nord a
décidé de faire sa tourner en tracteur
je n'ai pas le choix il y a des des
patientes très âgées qui m'attendent et
donc dans ce contexte d'alléa climatique
à répétition et bien certaines communes
sont abandonnées par leurs assurances
c'est le cas dans les Pyrénées
Orientales c'est à la Une du journal
L'Indépendant à torille commune de 3800
habitants le maire explique que le
contrat d'assurance va passer de 47000 €
par an à 147000 € le maire appelle donc
l'état à l'aide face à un phénomène qui
touche de nombreuses communes sur le
territoire français et il demande un
fond de sauvegarde des collectivités
territoriales Alex a 5 ans c'était la
naissance du mouvement des gilets jaunes
et oui c'est à la une de l'Union le
journal hardardenis puisque le 7
novembre 2018 à Charleville mésier pour
la première fois appariss apparaissaient
les gilets jaunes en marge d'un conseil
des ministres qui avait été délocalisé
par Emmanuel Macron à Charleville mière
dans la cité d'Arthur rimbaau certains
anciens gilets jaunes se souviennent de
cette lutte avec amertume qui selon eux
a été discrédité à cause des black
blocks dans les cortèges de
manifestation c'était toujours une
colère face à la hausse des prix colère
qui existe toujours face à l'inflation
mais aujourd'hui les gens ont peur de
descendre dans la rue estime Laurent
ancien gilets jaune merci Alex merci
beaucoup Yan BR Boyet pour ce débat sur
le projet de loi immigration merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 18h Thomas HUG pour sens
public et nous on se retrouve demain
très bonne
journal